this video is sponsored by blue apron
[Music]
hey guys Jared again if there's one
thing we at wisecrack consume more than
caffeine it in content we're constantly
analyzing movies shows and video games
while our body slowly wastes away
unfortunately our efforts don't always
pan out some properties just aren't as
insightful as we'd like such as the case
of Suicide Squad when we spent hours
discussing only to come up and be
handled there were a lot of
underwhelming films in 2016 but Suicide
Squad is a unique disaster Warner
Brothers thought the trailer was so much
better than the actual movie they
decided to hire the trailer company to
functionally rewrite the movie wondering
why the first 30 minutes feels like a
music video with too much neon
expedition thank the marketing team to
be fair though the trailer was pretty
awesome
but despite the fact the movie got hacks
this [ __ ] Suicide Squad is still
ambitious and that's what this new
wisecrack format is all about breaking
down media that doesn't quite work and
seeing what we can learn from it anyway
think about is a kind of autopsy or the
wisecrack version of a participation
trophy welcome to this special wisecrack
edition on Suicide Squad this is another
experiment for us so if you want us to
do more let us know in the comments the
hallmark of a thought-provoking movie is
its ability to introduce a theme and
develop it through conflict characters
visuals etc this theme in theory should
inspire thought or feeling for the
viewer for instance order versus chaos
in the Dark Knight family versus the
family in The Godfather
that's my family truth versus media
narrative in gone girl in my defense and
the merits of punching Nazis in Captain
America in Suicide Squad the primary
theme is control one dickbag guards
control and abuse the main characters
who are appropriately powerless
prisoners - Amanda Waller and Rick Flagg
control the squad with a device that
kills them if they don't stay in line
three The Enchantress battles for
control over the body of archaeologist
June moon for Amanda Waller controls the
Enchantress like stabbing her heart when
she doesn't stay in line five Amanda
Waller also controls reflect by
exploiting his love affair with June
I happen tonight and not the moment is
now he'll follow my orders element 6 The
Enchantress controls people by turning
them into slave monsters 7 Enchantress's
brother takes control of this guy 8
Diablo loses control and accidentally
kills his family I am mad and lose
control
9 The Joker controls Harley Quinn's
through their abusive relationship her
jacket even says property of the Joker
we've seen this theme of control
throughout the Snyder DC Universe put
our cards on the table in general even
you can't control a Man of Steel were
forced to ask ourselves when metahumans
with godlike powers walk the earth
how can mankind maintain control of
their own society the answer better hope
one of them is going to be humanity
Savior and preserve law and order then
in Batman V Superman we ask but what if
this benevolent Savior goes dark and
trigger-happy like that man he has the
power to wipe out the entire generation
if we believe there's even a 1% chance
that he is our enemy we have to take it
as an absolute how will mankind maintain
order then the answer won't happen
because Superman is [ __ ] Jesus
and he'll even sacrifice himself for
Humanity this is where Suicide Squad
enters the picture now that Earth's
metahuman bodyguard is dead how far must
humanity go to maintain control the
world changed when Superman flew across
the sky and then it changed again when
he didn't and that is why I'm here if
Batman V Superman explored the
ramifications of a god-like being who
can wield overwhelming power over
humanity then Suicide Squad is the
opposite it explores the ramifications
of humans wielding overwhelming power in
order to fight godlike being or at least
it should looking at Superman who shared
our values the next Superman might not
playing with fire Manta fighting fire
with fire Suicide Squad further explores
this dynamic best reflected in the
painting in Batman V Superman Lex Luthor
uses it to remind us that even Satan
started as an angel that should be
upside down the devil's don't come from
Hell beneath us now
he of course is talking about Superman
who like Satan could go apeshit evil at
any moment similarly Amanda Waller is
compared to the divine twice in the film
once as God and once as the devil a
usual
maybe behold the voice of God will
amanda waller a righteous government
official fall like Satan in the same way
Lex
assume Superman would will her quest for
control go too far and world a flying
man and monstrous this is the only way
to protect our country so what we've got
here is a pretty cool formatic setup one
that's right for all kinds of juicy
moral conundrum like is tyrannical
control necessary to combat existential
threat like in The Dark Knight you're
wrong
I've gotta find this man at what cost or
is that kind of oppression evil no
matter its justification it's like in
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
well Suicide Squad is neither so a quick
recap at the end the squad confronts
enchantress who invites them to join her
and fight those who have caged them ie
Amanda Waller and the government the
squad says screw you killed her and then
goes back to being jailed in their
Guantanamo inspired hell herein lies the
film's identity crisis as an anti
superhero movie the film is asking you
to identify with the prisoners they have
daughters regrets or are the victims of
emotional abuse and like most people are
seeking freedom freedom and freedom so
we see the humanity of the so-called
villains while we see the lack of
humanity of those in power that is just
a mean lady it makes sense that the anti
superhero movie would use tyrannical
control to complicate the divide between
the good establishments and the evil
supervillain what makes you think you
could control because getting people to
act against their own self-interest for
the national cares of the United States
is what I do for it even The Enchantress
is a victim of control a great
opportunity for some somatic interplay
should we identify with The Enchantress
as we do the Suicide Squad and if not
why their inhumane exertion of control
makes us identify with the squad and
question it's overused by the government
wretched everything ingrown felony drug
you unfortunately instead of developing
this moral gray area the film takes
refuge in the lamest of superhero movie
tropes making in tantras another bland
evil villain who wants to destroy the
world with an arbitrary doomsday machine
and a super vague motivation what is she
talking about she lamenting that we're
all glued to our Google phones and
Kindle pads I don't see any indication
of that in any DC movie so this is just
nonsense but I digress
the film is set up to add some really
interesting questions about the
characterization of evil in comic book
movies what does evil look like when our
protagonists are bad guys who have been
oppressed the bad guys are bad guys who
have been oppressed and the people
pulling everyone's strings are also bad
guys what is real evil in a world like
this they're evil dollars the film
dances around something insightful wrong
chosen to sin and that wears part of it
is they're going to blame us for the
whole thing don't forget we're the bad
guys but in the end all nuance is thrown
out the window
and evil is just lazily labeled as the
thing that wants to destroy the world
ladies you are evil she's trying to take
over the world why is this a problem
well it Rob's the themes of control and
oppression of any meaning it neither
develops the statement that oppressive
power is necessary since ultimately the
squad kills enchantress of their own
accord he's my friend nor does it
suggest that oppressive power is evil
since Waller essentially wins and her
corrupt status quo is reinstated in fact
those who have been put under the
control of other people almost
unilaterally get the shaft The
Enchantress dies Diablo dies the squad
goes back to the slammer and Harley
Quinn isn't even free from the Joker who
treats her like a possession you know
why my gift to this handsome hahaha so
is the film saying that control is a
necessary evil or does it stress the
value of freedom neither really it's
more of a movie about subjugated people
defending their own imprisonment against
someone who's also been a victim of
control but not in a cool way it's just
a man
and speaking of messes one of the
biggest criticisms leveled at the film
is that Jared Leto's Joker serves no
purpose this is mostly true however the
only part in which the Joker seems to
contribute to the thematic discussion is
in this point do not say this oath
topless Lee desire become surrender
surrender power okay so desire becomes
surrender surrender becomes power
alright does this manifest itself in the
film or is this just deliberately
cryptic edge porn [ __ ] if we look at
the end of the film we sort of see this
play out in order to stop the squad from
fording her plan of world domination the
enchantress seduces them by showing them
their desires harley dreams of a normal
life with the Joker Deadshot dreams
about killing Batman and Diablo dreams
of having his family back desire makes
them want to surrender and by
surrendering they would grant
enchantress power over them so this sort
of works but does it actually say
anything about the nature of control and
its relation to desire and surrender in
the final cut of the film no but there
are hints of an attempt to do so it
seems like the writer was trying to
establish an arc with Harley Quinn's
relation to desire surrender and power
hey I lost my puddin but you can get him
back right oh I can anything you want at
the beginning she submits to desire by
letting the Joker dominate her but then
at the end she rejects desire and
doesn't let the Enchantress dominate her
problem is this isn't any kind of lesson
for Harley she doesn't have a paradigm
shifting moment where she refuses to let
her desires become the power of others
instead she's right back under the thumb
of the Joker so does this line develop
the theme of control in any meaningful
way
so in conclusion there's a spark of
intelligence and Suicide Squad enough to
tell that there were likely earlier
versions of the film abandoned by the
studio that would have been so much
better but until someone emails me a
much guarded copy of the original script
wink wink we can only ruminate on what
may have
Phin hope you guys enjoyed this let us
know if you want us to do more media
autopsies in the comments below
thanks a lot guys P but if there's one
thing I like getting sent to me more
than early screenplays for butchered
movies it's delicious free food and blue
apron has already got me covered on that
if you're one of the first 100 wisecrack
fans to sign up at the link below in the
description it might be your next
favorite thing too for real blue apron
is offering three free meals to the
first hundred wisecrack fans who sign up
so make sure to do it at the link in the
description below blue apron delivers
farm-fresh ingredients that look and
taste awesome they sent us all the
ingredients to make roasted pork with
apple walnut and farro salad and while
we are far from chefs we had no problem
following the easy directions with all
the pre measured ingredients to cook a
super yummy meal and we had a ton of fun
doing it and by that I mean I had a lot
of fun watching the interns make it if
you love food and want an easy way to
cook great meals at home check out blue
apron they deliver fresh ingredients
with delicious recipes and it all comes
in a refrigerated box so ingredients
stay good even if you're not home when
it arrived shipping is always free and
you can skip or cancel service at any
time so if you're wanting to try out new
meals and hate going to the grocery
store as much as I do or love the idea
of fresh ingredients delivered to your
door check out blue apron at the link of
the description below and remember the
first hundred wisecrack fans to sign up
with that link get three free meals
thanks to blue apron for sponsoring this
video that's all for now guys all this
talking is made me pretty hungry don't
forget to subscribe peace
you
[Music]